Here is what will change for foreigners in France.
The law
immigration was adopted by the Senate this afternoon.
Here are the main changes,
the state's medical aid has been abolished
and replaced for emergency medical assistance.
As a result,
all health care expenses will no longer be reimbursed,
in other words,
only serious diseases.
Pregnancy-related care
and vaccination will be reimbursed.
Allowances will now be abolished
for foreigners
not being able to justify more than 5 years of
residence in France.
This announces the end of the APL
and family allowances.
There will be no more restrictions on octf.
Thus, even
people
present for more than 10 years in France,
to marry or the parents of a French minor
will no longer be protected against.
The Senate also abolished the automaticity of the
right of the ground.
It will now be necessary to
demonstrate its
desire to obtain French nationality
from 16 years old.
It cannot be obtained
if the person has been sentenced to 1 penalty equals
or more than 6 months imprisonment.
This law passed by the Senate
must pass to the National Assembly on 11/12.